comprendre la crise que traverse tristan
on va recevoir lille est forte elle est
la présidente de l'entreprise merci
d'être là madame fortin c'est une
décision évidemment comprend pas de
gaieté de coeur ni à la légère c'est une
question de survie pour vous oui en fait
l'objectif principal c'est de renégocier
les beaux parce qu'on peut plus
permettre d'avoir des magasins qui sont
pas rentables
donc c'est pas dans l'adn de
l'entrepreneur ou des entrepreneurs
d'opter pour une solution comme ça mais
aujourd'hui on pense que c'est la
meilleure solution pour assurer la
pérennité de l'entreprise puis de se
donner les moyens de faire les
investissements requis vu la rapidité
avec laquelle les habitudes d'achat des
consommateurs changent effectivement
évidemment et plusieurs détaillants qui
se retrouve dans une situation similaire
c'est l'effet de la pandémie entre
autres mais est ce que vous aviez des
défis avant la crise et les changements
d'habitudes de consommateurs ont
commencé bien avant la crise
donc on s'adapte et on innovait depuis
plusieurs années mais c'est sûr que la
crise a accentué et accélérer le besoin
de se réinventer puis de revoir notre
modèle d'affaires mais surtout d'avoir
des loyers qui font du sens le quand en
proportion des ventes qu'on fait alors
c'est sûr qu'avec la pandémie plus de
trois mois sans revenus générés par les
boutiques cesser
ça a un impact monstrueux sur nos
mobiles en est d'autant plus madame
fortin si je ne m'abuse de la plupart de
vos magasins sont situés dans des
centres commerciaux alors c'est dans ces
centres à l'heure où on a pu ouvrir
vraiment vers la toute fin dans la
dernière phase du des confidences à
ajouter à vos difficultés ça j'imagine
absolument ça fait un peu plus de deux
semaines que tous nos magasins sont
réouverts on a été longtemps
sept ont été les dernières et ouvrir
parce qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de
magazines dans la grande région de
montréal qui était vraiment la dernière
région
les derniers centres commerciaux qui ont
pu réouvrir oui est ce que les clients
sont quand même de retour depuis la
réouverture vous peut-être pas assez
pour vous sortir du gouffre est ce que
vous sentez un retour de la clientèle
les trafics sont très très à la baisse
ceci dit les gens qui sont en magasin
sont là pour pour acheter mais c'est sûr
que les trafics le cd baisse de 70 60 70
50 50 et 80 % de baisse de trafic dans
les centres commerciaux
bon là à partir de maintenant vous
demander la protection des crues d'une
autre de quelle manière vous comptez
rebondir est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
restructuration le l'objectif principal
de notre décision de faire un
de faire un dépôt d'avis d'intention
c'est vraiment la négociation avec les
centres commerciaux
c'est ce qui va nous permettre de
pouvoir
de pouvoir concevoir lot de pouvoir
planifier la pérennité de l'entreprise
alors c'est vraiment de la négociation
avec les centres commerciaux on n'a pas
énormément on a pas de licenciements
prévus c'est vraiment les centres comme
c'est vraiment nos beaux qui notre ratio
loyers sur vente dans certains magasins
ne fait plus de sens c'est ce que les
nouvelles réalités quand même un message
positif que vous envoyez à vos employés
ils sont 650 à peu près dont vous ne
prévoyez pas de licenciement pour
l'instant mais est ce que la taille de
votre réseau pourraient être réduits des
succursales fermées le siège social
univers québécois mais on les
détaillants alors notre objectif n'est
pas de fermer des magasins mais c'est
sûr qu'on ne peut pas supporter des
magasins qui sont peu rentables alors
dépendamment de la collaboration qu'on
aura des centres commerciaux
on pourra prendre les décisions à ce
moment là
mais notre objectif c'est vraiment
d'opérer des magasins profitable et vous
êtes parmi les rares détaillants
québécois à produire encore une partie
de vos vêtements ici vous avez une usine
en esprit est ce que ce modèle de
production locale ça va tenir
on a deux usines on a une usine à
cookshire une usine à farnham les deux
les deux en estrie c'est sûr que on
investit beaucoup d'argent dans les dans
les 2 dans les dernières années pour
maintenir la production aussi parce que
ça nous tenait à coeur c'est important
pour nous cependant la pandémie bon le
vus on n'aurait jamais pu trouver des
solutions là dans le médical ou pouvoir
produire changer notre changer notre
production aussi rapidement qu'on le
fait si on n'avait pas nos propres
usines et la seule référence vous avez
produit des visières entre autres est ce
que ça vous a permis de limiter les
pertes jusqu'à un certain point ça ne te
permis de passer à travers la crise du
coc vide sans accès à des marges de
crédit qu'on n'a plus depuis le début
mai de la banque alors avec une gestion
serrée puis des revenus du médical ça
fait qu'on a quand même réussi à passer
à se rendre à aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui quand même le
sens sinon on aurait dû faire ça il ya
plusieurs mois
pressant madame fortin est une
entreprise familiale vous avez un
attachement particulier ce pas comme des
actionnaires avec une entreprise comment
vous vivez cette crise là aujourd'hui
c'est sûr que c'est une difficile
c'est sur ces conditions qu'on a pris à
la légère ça fait plusieurs semaines
qu'on y réfléchisse qu'on évalue les
alternatives qu'on essaie d'éviter cette
solution-là fait qu'il ya un gros c'est
sûr qu'ils aient un côté émotif très
très important dans tout ça et on ne
veut pas perdre la confiance de nos
employés la confiance de nos partenaires
de nos fournisseurs la confiance de nos
clients
c'est notre raison d'être et notre
mission c'est toujours ce qui nous tient
encore à coeur le plus alors cessé on a
dû mettre les émotions de côté puis
prendre une décision d'affaires pour
justement assurer un futur prometteur
pour eux oui l'entreprise vraiment on
vous le souhaite l'a dit comme on le
mentionnait c'est difficile pour
plusieurs autres détaillants est ce que
dans ce contexte là alors qu'on en a
plusieurs qui font plusieurs qui vont
négocier aussi avec les centres
commerciaux est ce que est ce que vous
êtes confiante pour l'avenir de tristan
oui absolument
c'était en fait ce qui nous motive à
faire cette entamé ce processus là parce
que sinon je serais pas c'est pas de
gaîté de coeur qu'on fait c'est vraiment
pour l'entreprise pour le bien de
l'entreprise qu'on le sait madame fortin
jour merci beaucoup d'avoir été là je
souhaite bonne chance pour la suite
merci